[Music]
in the beginning when we started with
gomad it was just an itch my operational
manager at me I went to pick up some
vegetables at my associates company
where the vdab
was presenting three official refugees
the focus of it was difficult for me
because I didn't had any experience here
in Belgium about work
[Music]
in case I said no problem I will give
you whatever give you Joe
there was something in their eyes you
saw that they wanted to work so they
came first day
hi guys English how are you no answer
there wasn't a word of Dutch coming out
of their mouth so second week started
during the weekend I was the how can I
improve that okay let's start some Dutch
courses that during working hours
I started instantly giving Dutch courses
myself to our people the three people
after two months became seven after
three months became them and now you had
another update 270 colleagues and 15 of
them are official refugees so after a
few months later increase of say that
now we know that you can do all of these
machines and so so we want to make you a
team leader it's not me that you can
change the world in the way that I think
now I need to take action and I need to
create the new world I want to create a
comfortable world to living but that
worlds should be an inclusive world for
the future also I'm so happy because if
you have job you get money you have a
house you have a relaxed life so it's
good for me I'm happy
you